next round fritz u
17 90
so closed in january with springer
ag
2 i know from a long time ago that
you can play five each
very early on three he really wants to
play
b4 representation well he obviously wants to look at that
if i take away lion
3d is coming  of course he comes to put on the
black
squares not really stupid
good comes
but ignore
so one hundred percent does
n't fit the whole thing to the chat and all the
other stuff
that's where we are
now but I should really
threaten to take the path
he probably really has
no compensation added value now not
served
tom b 1 or so
yes
yes it would be interesting if i take the five
game 7
because i would have 4 anyway
i guess he would like to play c4 himself to
get the concreted entrance to
the 5 again i run the rc44 again
now  reacts
ok I really threaten it does
n't do that anymore to take on c4 but
there's nothing wrong with just
hitting
j  now move
with what do we take with the queen
now lives a nice position with the
weak pawn on it the
three he actually has no special
counterweight
ask now how best to stand there
nice b66 was so very
comfortable
but he can play gymnastics club  and
I don't really know how he
should jump
can of course
just play b61 bishop b7
hmm
well I can double on the deele here
and not move any pawns on the
queenside so that he's not weak
there can't do anything where I can
make an active position  the four at most
but
that speaks I think more than a
dozen yes had actually played
so I am here now take then
the g7
king exchanges if necessary
yes well take should be better than
the other
ok I didn’t expect
that because I thought so
I wouldn't really like to give up the four here now, but the player who transfers the five isn't totally stupid, I
'll introduce myself again  continue on
top of the three so I would have to play a bit faster
yes okay that is of course
a great relief that he simply
exchanges then I don’t have to worry about
springer ag 5 or something like that
now only the
weak pawn remains over this,
there can’t do anything dynamically
somehow make e5 sometime
if i get two or three moves
without being disturbed here
so b6 speaks nothing against
the five i can take with the queens he
does anyway but
i can take with the name
or not
at the moment maybe i want to
yes but i can also give that up
dörfer c 6263 i thought maybe an
idea
ok that was check so and now finally the throne there
from the diagonal still out
minute 19 always ask me what i
actually always invest time in
so the three hangs  now so often
you can't really cover well
tomi 4 canal maybe
but then i still have 25 so
well  since we are now 5 and he is direct
to
me so far she only in check
now
threatens also knight f2
should actually be over now
he without
you they have no move
like yes yes fine okay I can't
just take
can here yet  put in
check I also have the four
if necessary so and now simply the exchange
everything
is this summarized emphasize
yes it can be shown to the end
probably
so what should make it useful because
some finally put
him I wanted to say but now  he gave
up
well actually like that and
gave over 70 points after all